Ahora que ya sabemos que el movimiento
circular uniformemente variado, o MCUV,
es un movimiento en trayectoria circular con la
aceleración constante, y que también conocemos
sus ecuaciones, es el momento perfecto para que
hablemos de las gráficas más importantes que
se pueden representar en el movimiento circular
uniformemente variado. Vamos a ver tres gráficas:
la gráfica de cambio de la aceleración angular
como función del tiempo, la gráfica del cambio
de la velocidad angular como una función del
tiempo y la gráfica del cambio de la posición
angular también como función del tiempo. Así que
primero, recordemos qué es la posición angular,
qué es la velocidad angular y qué es la
aceleración angular. Primero, podemos
decir que la posición angular φ es una magnitud
angular que representa el ángulo que forma en
cada momento el vector de posición de un cuerpo;
por su parte, la velocidad angular representa
el desplazamiento angular, es decir, delta de
φ, experimentado por un cuerpo en cada unidad
de tiempo; mientras que la aceleración angular
representa la variación de la velocidad angular,
es decir delta de ω, respecto al tiempo. Así
que empecemos con la gráfica de la aceleración
angular como función del tiempo. Para esto,
pensemos en un ejemplo de la vida real,
¿qué tal un ventilador? Imaginemos que las aspas
de este ventilador se mueven en un MCUV, bueno,
en un movimiento circular uniformemente variado
la aceleración angular no cambia, es constante
¿cierto? Esto quiere decir que las aspas tienen
el mismo cambio de velocidad en tiempos iguales,
entonces, la gráfica de la aceleración angular
contra el tiempo de un movimiento circular
uniformemente variado muestra que la aceleración
angular, que se mide en rad•s², es constante en
todo momento, ya que la aceleración no cambia por
definición. Si la aceleración angular es positiva,
tendremos una recta constante por encima
del eje X, es decir, el ventilador parte
del reposo y está aumentando su velocidad hasta
alcanzar su velocidad máxima. Mientras que si la
aceleración angular es negativa, tendremos una
recta constante por debajo del eje X, es decir,
el ventilador va disminuyendo su velocidad
hasta llegar al reposo. Podríamos pensar que
se va "apagando" desde la velocidad máxima. Ahora
bien, si pensamos en el área debajo de esta recta
constante de la aceleración positiva, o por arriba
de la recta constante de la aceleración en el caso
de ser negativa, de un tiempo inicial a uno final,
entonces ¿qué crees que represente? Bueno, sabemos
que ω = ω₀ + αt, o, dicho de otra manera: ω - ω₀
= αt, ¿cierto? Ahora bien, si nos fijamos en el
área de este rectángulo, estamos multiplicando el
tiempo, que es la base de este rectángulo, por la
altura, que es la aceleración angular. Entonces,
para un intervalo de tiempo dado, el área bajo
la curva de la aceleración angular, o sobre
la curva en caso de tener una desaceleración,
nos da la diferencia o el cambio en la velocidad
angular, es decir, el área que representamos aquí
nos da el cambio en la velocidad angular, lo cual
tiene mucho sentido. Ahora bien, ¿qué pasará en la
gráfica del cambio de la velocidad angular también
como función del tiempo? Pausa el video y piénsalo
antes de que lo trabajemos juntos. Bien, en el
eje horizontal, el eje X, de nuevo pondremos
el tiempo y en el eje vertical, la velocidad
angular. La velocidad angular se mide en rad•s,
y aumenta o disminuye de manera uniforme con el
paso del tiempo, ya que tenemos un movimiento
con aceleración angular constante. Recuerda, eso
quiere decir que hay cambios de velocidad angular
iguales en tiempos iguales. Podemos ver que la
ecuación ω = ω₀ + αt es la ecuación de una recta
de la forma y = mx + b, donde en este caso m = α y
b = ω₀. De nuevo podemos distinguir dos casos: si
la aceleración es positiva, entonces tendremos una
recta con pendiente positiva, es decir, de nuevo
tenemos la idea de cambios positivos iguales en
la velocidad angular en tiempos iguales. De nuevo
puedes pensar que el ventilador está aumentando
de velocidad desde el arranque y, por lo tanto,
la velocidad aumenta. De hecho, podemos
darnos cuenta de que su pendiente, es decir,
la tangente del ángulo que forma con respecto a la
horizontal, es la aceleración. Siguiendo la misma
lógica, si la aceleración es negativa, entonces
tendremos una recta con pendiente negativa,
y por lo tanto tendremos cambios descendentes
iguales en tiempos iguales, es decir, una recta
descendente. El ventilador disminuye su velocidad
cuando lo apagamos hasta llegar al reposo; de
nuevo su pendiente será su aceleración. Ahora ¿qué
representará el área bajo la curva de la velocidad
angular? Pausa el video y piénsalo un poco. Bueno,
esta gráfica es la del área debajo de la curva de
velocidad angular contra el tiempo. Para calcular
el área debajo de la curva, podemos dividirla,
primero, en un rectángulo que tenga como área ω₀t,
es decir, este rectángulo que tenemos aquí, más
este triángulo que -observa- tiene como altura ω
- ω₀, y la base es t; entonces su área es ω - ω₀,
todo esto por t entre 2. Y bueno, sin perder
generalidad, podemos decir que t₀ = 0. Así que
el área total bajo la curva será: A = ω₀t + (ω
- ω₀) t/2. Ahora bien, a partir de la ecuación
de la velocidad angular podemos obtener que: ω -
ω₀ = αt. Utilizando esto, entonces, el área es,
bueno: ω₀t más, y en lugar de poner ω - ω₀,
pondremos (αt) t /2, lo cual me dará: ω₀t + αt² /
2. Bien, ya tenemos la expresión para el área
total bajo la curva de la velocidad angular contra
el tiempo. Antes de terminar la interpretación de
esta área, es un excelente momento de presentar la
última expresión que vamos a trabajar en este
video, es decir, la posición angular. Tenemos
que φ = φ₀ + ω₀t + 1/2 αt²; y esta expresión ¿no
se parece mucho a lo que acabamos de encontrar?
¡Claro!, si pasamos φ₀ del otro lado de la
ecuación, vamos a tener que: φ - φ₀ = ω₀t + 1/2
αt². Y es justo la expresión que encontramos
para el área, es decir: A = φ - φ₀, que, como ya
sabemos, es igual a ω₀t + 1/2 αt², dicho de otra
manera, acabamos de encontrar que el área bajo
la curva de la velocidad angular que buscábamos es
el cambio de la posición angular. Así que ya está,
podemos decir que el área que representamos
aquí nos da el cambio en la posición angular,
lo cual tiene mucho sentido. Por último, pero no
por eso menos importante, tenemos la gráfica de
la posición angular como función del tiempo.
Para ello, utilizaremos la última fórmula
que presentamos al final del ejercicio anterior.
¿Cómo se ve esta gráfica? Pausa de nuevo el video
e intenta esbozar su gráfica y ver si coincide
con la que trabajaremos juntos. ¿Cómo se verá la
gráfica de la posición angular a través del tiempo
en un movimiento circular uniformemente variado?
Bueno, pondremos en el eje horizontal, el eje
X, al tiempo y en el eje vertical la posición
angular, que denotamos con la letra griega φ.
Como es una función cuadrática, se tiene que
ver distinta a la función anterior, ¿estás de
acuerdo? Tenemos t², entonces es de la forma:
y = ax² + bx + c, por lo que φ₀ será el valor
donde cortamos a la ordenada. La posición angular,
medida en radianes según las unidades del
sistema internacional, aumenta o disminuye
de manera no uniforme con el paso del tiempo.
Podemos distinguir dos casos dependiendo de que
la aceleración angular sea positiva o negativa, es
decir, si el valor de α es mayor o menor que cero.
Observa: cuando el tiempo aumenta, entonces la
posición angular también aumentará; sin embargo,
la forma en la que aumentará dependerá del signo
de la aceleración: si la aceleración es positiva,
entonces la velocidad aumentará, lo que hará que
la posición también aumente cada vez más rápido.
Puedes ver que las aspas del ventilador se siguen
moviendo y lo hacen cada vez más rápido. Por otra
parte, si la aceleración es negativa, la velocidad
irá disminuyendo, lo que implica que el ventilador
seguirá aumentando su posición angular, seguirá
moviéndose, pero esta vez cada vez más lento. Por
ejemplo, al apagar el ventilador la velocidad
de las aspas empieza a disminuir, las aspas
se seguirán moviendo en el mismo sentido cada vez
más lento, pero la posición angular aumenta aunque
cada vez más lento hasta pararse por completo. Así
que ahora ya sabemos cómo se ven las gráficas de
la posición angular, la velocidad angular y la
aceleración angular con respecto del tiempo en
un movimiento circular uniformemente variado.
Espero te sea útil para entender un poco más,
de manera gráfica, en qué consiste este movimiento
y puedas apoyarte en estas ideas para los
ejercicios que encuentres en un futuro. Esto es
todo por este video, nos vemos en el siguiente.